لغه الحرب لا تقتصر فقط على تحقيق
الانتصارات على ارض الميدان بل تمتد الى
استعراض العضلات ايضا فيما يعرف بالحرب
النفسيه في هذا السياق اعلنت روسيا اجراء
تجربه ناجحه لاطلاق صاروخ باليستي عابر
للقارات وصفته بالمتقدم وتاتي هذه التجربه
الصاروخيه بعد اسابيع من تعليق روسيا
مشاركتها في اخر اتفاق للحد من الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه مع الولايات المتحده هذا
وكشفت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الصاروخ
انطلق من مقاطعه استرخان الروسيه ونجح في
ضرب هدف وهمي في ميدان للتدريب بكازاخستان
ولم تحدد وزاره الدفاع الروسيه دائما نوع
الصاروخ المستخدم لكنها ذكرت ان الهدف من
هذه التجربه هو اختبار معدات قتاليه
متطوره لصواريخ باليستيه عابره للقارات
وعلى الارجح فان الامر يتعلق بصواريخ
سرمات الروسيه الاسرع من الصوت والتي اكد
الرئيس روسيا فلاديمير بوتين سابقا انها
ستكون جاهزه في المستقبل القريب وينتمي
صاروخ صارمه
الى صواريخ الجيل الخامس الحديثه ويطلق
عليها من قبل المعسكر الغربي اسم الشيطان
اثنين ويستطيع هذا الصاروخ ضرب اهداف على
بعد اكثر من 11 الف كيلو متر وهذا يعني ان
بوسعه ضرب اوروبا وامريكا بكل سهوله ويقول
خبراء غربيون ان هذا الصاروخ يستطيع حمل
عشره رؤوس نوويه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات